[inaudible].
All right.
So I want to shift a little bit to foreign
policy because I think that's sort of,
uh, one of your, one of your, would you
say that's one of your main strengths?
So my claim to fame was counter
terrorism and stuff like this, but,
but really deep down, I'm a strategy wank.
Yeah. Grand Strategy is my thing. Okay.
So we'll talk,
we'll talk in the lens and strategy then.
So as we're taping this right now,
I mentioned earlier, it's gonna,
it's gonna sit on the shelf
for a couple of days. Um,
so I don't want to get too lost
in anything that happened today,
but at the moment it's a little
upside down in Syria. We don't,
there might've been strikes already
from when we're taping this.
Hungary just had elections. Um, in your
Wikipedia that I referenced earlier,
it says you work through for the guy
who just won you apparently you never
worked for him. You don't want to face
potty. I wasn't victim Audubon's advising,
which is what it says. We
have the PD at least. Um,
what's your general thoughts on
foreign policy strategy? Like,
what is a sensible
policy and, and his Trump
applying that view. Uh,
first things first,
uh,
the great irony of all nation is that
we are the most powerful nation in the
world has ever seen.
And until recently we have been the
dumbest and most a strategic. I mean,
we haven't done,
we haven't thought or acted
strategically since about 1989.
November the ninth when the Berlin
Wall fell. And this is, you know, um,
how have we active, what would you
say that since then it's just, Oh,
well we want security.
Nineties was just this kind of confused.
What is national security about
lurching for the snooze button.
Just who are the threats?
Is it China is a weapons of mass
destruction and say you can slog it.
It was just a mess.
And then we had 2001 and nine 11,
and we had just neo con disasters.
There's not an accident.
These guys were former Trotskyites
because there's so naive,
the way they look at the world,
that we're going to create democracy
at the end of a gun barrel in a country
with 36 languages that defeated Alexander
the Great and the British empire and
the Soviets. You couldn't be stupid or
if you tried. So, you know, we, we, we,
we've done some very, very foolish things
because we haven't stuck to the basics.
Strategy at the end of the
day is about one thing.
It's about prioritization
based upon interests, right?
You've got to say some things are more
important than others. And guess what?
Some countries are more important than
others. And in a postmodern secular world,
you're not allowed to or
know all countries or Vanuatu
is as important as Turkey
wrong. It's partly, I mean, I love
the people that I out too, but no,
it's not a geo strategic input to the,
to the country of America. So number one,
we have to prioritize.
And I think this administration,
I doff my cap to Nadia, shadow
low, uh, uh, HR mcmasters deputy,
she held the pen in the meetings that
I was in on the new national security
strategy of America.
And I tell you, David,
it is the first document of that name
in 30 years that deserves the name
national security strategy.
Every administration has them.
This is the first one that says, this is
what we stand for. These are our values,
these are our friends,
these are our enemies and this is what
we're going to prioritize. Prior to that,
it was laundry list of well we're
going to have to front walls,
we're going to save the whales. And you
know, no. So you have to prioritize.
And finally this administration
is about America first. Uh,
we are not isolationists
nor are we interventionists.
This is really annoys me that if you're
a conservative for 20 years you were
given two options,
button a invade other people's
countries and occupy them button B,
B around the Sta and close the,
you know,
the curtains on the Pacific
and the Atlantic and say,
we don't care about anybody else.
Well guess what is the most
powerful nation in the world?
There is a large pallet of options.
It's gotta be something in the middle of
their, yeah. So it's about being smart.
It's about our interests.
And to summarize the president's approach,
this isn't official,
but I like it.
We have numerous former generals and
active generals from the Marine Corps at
the highest level of the administration
should have the joint chiefs,
Chief of staff,
secretary defense.
And the interesting thing is they all
come from the same Marine Corps division,
not just the Marine Corps, the same
division. And that division has a motto,
no better friend, no worse
enemy. That's America first.
So when you see someone like John
Bolton, uh, now part of the cabinet,
and if you were to look on, you know, not
that you can get truth out of Twitter,
but the day it was happening,
you know,
everybody's saying this is going to
start world war three and you know,
just the general hysterics. And now John
Bolton is definitely private suspect.
More of a neo con then you're
comfortable with, is that,
I don't think it's fair
to them. Naoko I, I don't,
I don't think he's ideologically driven.
If you watch the videos that he,
you know,
we're recording of his speech is 20
years ago he was sounding very much like
Trump, we're American, we have interests.
You want to work with us, fight.
If you don't,
there's a problem.
So I think it's very telling that within
40 minutes of the president's tweet
about John Coming on board,
um,
massive Balkan gave an interview on Fox
and they asked them about what are you
going to be like as a
national security advisor?
And he gave a very interesting answer.
He quoted Dean Acheson and you know, the,
the, the Doyenne of foreign
policy in America. And uh,
I don't know if this is true story,
but John said the mattress
than was once once asked,
how do you have such a good relationship
with the president you serve and the
mattress and said, well, it's very easy.
We may disagree on policy issues,
but at the end of the day,
I never forget who was elected president.
And it wasn't me that uh,
John Bolton 2.0 he understands that
unlike his predecessor HR McMaster,
he's not there to lecture the president
or foist his version of what you should
do onto the commodity and chief.
He's at to be an honest broker and
provide a palliative options because guess
who gets to decide the person
who was elected president.
So I am very excited about John and I,
I'm,
I'm as excited about Mike Palm coming
from the CIA to the State Department that
we are in. Very good hands,
David. So how do you make sure if,
if it's between the pure isolationists
and, and the neo cons or something,
something like the nation builders,
something like that.
How do you make sure that not everything
that you do outside of our borders
becomes something much bigger? I mean,
look, we're still at war in Afghanistan.
I don't think anyone knows
why at the, I mean, can you,
can you tell me why we're
at war in Afghanistan? Can
anyone tell, tell you is why,
why we went, why we went to
Afghanistan in October of [inaudible].
One is the only reason we should be
that today. Nothing's changed. Okay?
The idea that goes go to school.
I love it.
I get it that people can listen to music
freely and the Taliban load execute you.
My parents lived under communism.
My father suffered under fascism.
He protected his fellow Jewish classmates
during the occupation of Budapest.
I get it.
I don't like those kinds of systems,
but there's only one reason we're there
to make sure that that piece of land
less would never ever again be used
to execute mass casualty attacks in
Manhattan, in Washington or in a
field in Pennsylvania. End of story.
It's not about building
a ring road around Kabul.
The not even the Soviets could finish.
It's not about building hospitals.
I'm sorry. You never make the
ideal, the enemy of the good.
What the president does is he looks
at things as questions of possibility.
You cannot be a massively successful
realtor in the toughest market in New York
or in the world which
in New York real estate.
If you have a filter that
distorts reality, I mean,
either this square footage is worth x
or it's not worth x according to the
market.
And that's how he approaches these issues.
So Afghanistan's only important to make
sure bad guys don't use it again to kill
Americans in America. So you, so
you would say, or at least if you,
if you had to guesstimate
basically what he believes,
you would say that he believes that
still keeping us there at the moment is
still accomplishing. Yeah. Oh, I don't
have to guesstimate. I can tell you that.
Yeah.
So you believe that as well because it
just seems unclear and it has nothing
that has nothing to do. He will.
He will never, I tell you right.
This 71 year old man who is now the most
powerful man in the world will never,
ever,
ever buy into a nation building scenario
anywhere outside of the United States.
Not happening for the next seven years.
End of story.
And the idea that you have my followers
on Twitter tearing their hair out,
the boltons going to house in Syria,
guys got a grip on reality.
And stop talking about crisis
actors and 10 fold hot garbage.
It's not going to happen while
the president's the president.
Well that I tweeted something to that
effect the day of the Bolton thing because
it also reminds me that people don't
understand basic deterrence that you have
to bring in people that you know,
talk a big game so that perhaps
radio hello. Yeah. Right.
The man who was going to take us to war.
What did he do?
I think the success in North Korea today
has in large part being pop had been
uh, uh, thanks to his tweets because
that's how you deal with the potatoes.
You make fun of them, they hate
that. And then you ridicule them,
right? And then you do what? You
scare them. Oh, and Lo and behold,
they want to negotiate for the
first time in 65 years. Well,
isn't that interesting?
Do you think there's any chance
he would ever give up his nukes?
About 3% because at that point, what
leverage does he have left? Right.
So that you still think it's worth having
the talks to figure out what we can,
absolutely. Because what's happened for
the last 25 years? Escalation, escalation,
escalation. I mean we, we have given into
nuclear blackmail since Bill Clinton. Uh,
so yeah, we, we have to
at the end of the day,
we have to remember in 1953 was not a
peace treaty in 1953 in Korea was a cease
firing and all MREs.
That is actually a war that's just
simply been frozen for 65 years.
Would be nice to have a little bit
of a peace treaty or something. Yeah.
How much of what's happening
in the world right now? Do you,
you must be thrilled,
I assume with everything going on at the
UN that Nikki Haley is basically walked
in there and, and John Bolton 2.0
yeah. Yeah. I mean, she strikes me as,
I almost wondered, did Trump really know
what he was getting with high Billy?
Yeah. Did anyone know? Anybody?
Did? Yeah. Where, where did the,
did you know her at all?
Where do you think that that of,
I don't know her as a friend.
Um, she found herself,
she found herself in more power to her.
What,
what usefulness do you see
in the UN at this point?
Because it seems like truly it seems
like the most corrupt should be backwards
pushed into the river. I mean really,
I mean, well, the buildings basically
now they're going to quote that and
go, you see, he was calling for,
to be knocking to the river. Um, look,
the idea was a good idea
in 1945 in San Francisco,
let's have an organization that stops
us from killing 60 million people again.
Um,
but when you lock in dictatorships
like China and Russia into the Security
Council with veto power
and then you create this,
this empire of UN organizations,
I mean,
has there been a year in the last 20
years that we haven't seen a UN scandal,
whether it's money for oil,
whether it's UN troops
raping children in Africa?
Have we seen it one year without
a UN scandal? I don't think so.
So try and reform it and if you calm was
questioned the validity of what it does
or forget. I don't talking about,
you know, the, the, the, the,
the children's rights organizations
and food, food security.
I'm talking about its main mission,
which is stability and safety.
It's failed abysmally. Yeah. What
do you make of the endless obsession with
Israel that something like 47 over the
last 51 resolutions are against Israel
and usually usually voted on by countries.
I'm sorry.
That alone is a reason to dissolve the UN.
I mean what a lack of moral compass,
what an utter bankruptcy of the morality
that there are nations in the world
that actually still have slavery going on.
Slavery where we're basic human rights
for individuals are not guaranteed based
upon sex based upon lifestyle choices.
And you're going to lambaste Israel, the
only real democracy in the Middle East.
Yeah,
I say I think you nailed it.
I mean that that in and of itself is a
reason enough to question the future of
the UN.
So is the u s sort of in an odd position
where it's like if we don't do anything,
nothing can get done sort of.
And that that then puts us endlessly
in these quagmires or at least in these
positions where we can either watch the
world burn or get involved in things
where we may end up adding to the burning
in the first place. Like for example,
you know with Russia going into Crimea,
they gave up their weapons, right?
They gave up the weapons and they said,
all right,
NATO is going to take care of us,
but what that really means is the United
States is going to take care of you,
and I'm not saying we should have
gone in and done anything there,
but that we're in this endless situation
now where it is either us there,
there is no international fighting.
When I was super careful not to
get caught in a binary dichotomy,
you can absolutely say a world without
American leadership is a more dangerous
world because it was for
the last day is look,
I mean we had a government that actually
said, we're going to lead from behind,
which is an oxymoron.
You cannot lead from behind.
We're going to have strategic patients,
which means we do nothing and
allow others to act. What happened?
You name it from China building fake
mandatory basis on fake islands to isis,
to Russia invading.
It was just a disaster.
We back the guy, then we got my
other guys, then we backed off there.
So yeah, to say that a welder on record
leadership is, is more dangerous,
is true, but that doesn't mean that we
have to fix everybody's problem and nuts.
That's where smart strategy
comes in where you say, look,
we have a moral duty to
espouse certain values,
but that doesn't mean we are responsible
for all human beings. Because,
because the American revolution
says the opposite, right?
Each nation is responsible,
the citizens are responsible.
If you don't like your system,
do something about it because guess what
we did against the most powerful empire
in the world. So, um, again,
it's about finding that happy medium
in the middle and being smart about it.
And again, we're not being
callous, being realistic,
right? There are atrocities everywhere
from Orlando to t three Yugoslavia,
Father American taxpayers are
gonna pay for fixing all of them.
Are we responsible? Are they responsible
for what's happening in their country?
Sure are the times when we
could perhaps help them. Uh Huh.
But it's a balance right,
to balance. All right, so let's shift
back to your book. So defeating Jihad,
it seems to me that the,
the main sort of narrative on
this is not that we can defeat it,
but we should live with it.
That there's a degree of it
with which we should just live,
which is don't carry knives
in London and it's, you know,
we're going to put up more barricades
so the trucks can't be driven into
buildings or into shopping centers or
just down the street and killing people
that we can't really defeat this ideology.
We just have to manage it.
I suspect you do not agree
with that premise. Oh,
because we've defeated ideologists before.
You can't look,
there are idiots who run around
with swats grand bands today.
I get it.
So Nazi-ism hasn't disappeared,
but we have made it so enough of that.
If you walk down the
street with a Nazi flag,
you will be rejected by society instantly.
The same thing with the KKK, right?
Saudi not with Che Guevara for the
hammer and sickle, right, right, right.
But there are ways to defeat ideologies
or to put them in a box where they're
laughable and everybody shuns them.
We have to do the same thing with
jihadism. This is my argument.
This is the conclusion of the book.
We have to be as effective in dealer
[inaudible] the message of GF because very
simply put killing jihadis is great,
but at the end of the day, uh,
body bags as a metric, not a good
metric. It didn't work in Vietnam.
Doesn't work today because guess what?
If you've got a recruiting pool that's
massive, not just recruit new jihadis.
So what's your victory
condition of victory condition
is when the life style of
jihad is no longer sexy from
Brussels to San Bernardino.
How do you do that?
You make a laughingstock.
You discredit that value
system. We're not asked. I mean,
white skinned Catholic isn't going to
do it right? But we help President Sisi,
we help King Abdullah of Jordan will
help MBS in Saudi Arabia. I mean, MBS,
the historic things he said,
I mean massive about Israel in just the
last few weeks. Yeah. That's how we win.
Because sooner or later
enough people say, Eh, uh,
those guys are losers.
That's how we win. Yeah.
But you only do that if you get
to talk about it. Truthfully.
You've gotta be able to talk
about the Koran, what Jihad means,
the history of the religion. Because
if you can't talk about it, honestly,
you're never going to treat it accurately.
Yeah.
We're not very good at that though. Well,
thanks. Political correctness, right?
I mean, imagine if you know, you're,
you're a doctor and you've got a
patient that comes in with third stage
lymphoma, but your hospital
administrator, because it's a scary word,
has banned the use of the word cancer.
You can't say it right.
It's just not allowed. Yeah. And then
you have to tell the patient what, well,
you know, you're dehydrated. Go home,
drink some water and take some aspirin.
What happens? You patient,
they die. It's the same thing.
If you can't diagnose a geo
strategical issue accurately,
however much money you throw at it,
you will not solve the problem.
So are you concerned at all that just
even if it's purely because of the way the
media frames things,
that perhaps Trump is not the right
person to lead the fight against this,
that for whatever,
whatever he's going to say about Jihad
or a radical Islamic terrorism or the
rest,
even if he said everything the exact way
that you wanted it to be said cleanly
and clearly and correctly
defined and all of that,
that he may not be the right messenger
on this just because of the filter it has
to get through to get to reality.
He's not the right messenger domestically
because of what political correctness
is wrought in our country.
But he is absolutely the right
messenger internationally.
Watch the video of his Riyadh speech.
Don't watch him.
Watch the 53 Mosley matter of heads of
state and the body language because man
did he guys,
you got a problem and your master and
your society's extremes that you have to
deal with it.
It was tough and you'd thing that'd
be all negative and arms crossed.
They were beaming.
Right.
Cc Abdulla we're going over finally find
a guy who understands our problem and
what is giving us tough love.
So yeah,
he is absolutely the right guy
to fix this internationally,
which is where it needs
to be fixed domestically.
Now the political correctness things going
to get in the way, the media insanity.
So do you think he has more support from
foreign heads of state and then we'll
ever have a sense.
I mean even if the g eight there was a
feeling of like that actually these guys
kinda liked him or I can tell you,
yeah,
I told people before the inauguration,
you have no idea.
Even if you voted for him,
you have no idea how successful he
will be internationally because he's a
straight shooter and
because he's an Alpha dog.
And guess what?
In a lot of places outside of Berkeley,
they like have that right,
because they know what
you're talking about.
They don't have to walk on eggshells.
They understand your direction. So, yeah,
internationally,
our prestige as a nation
has skyrocketed in,
you know, outside of the European
Union and maybe, you know,
certain century pin countries
exempted. Yeah, absolutely.
So I know we could do a whole
other show on this, but,
but very quickly just
on Russia and collusion,
as someone that has been
around the administration,
you've mentioned some of these people
already, Flynn, you know, down the road.
What can you tell me about that and is
there anything that people should be
worried about or do you think this is
all gonna actually points us back to the
Democrats, which every time it seems,
every time it seems to point to Trump,
you go a little bit further and then
you're going, oh whoa, wait a minute.
That was actually the Democrats
doing my good friend has a,
the best morning show in DC,
a m Chris plot of the radio host is
actually a national syndicated now.
And I have to credit him with this.
He says it's the,
it's the last scene from the hunt for
Red October when the bad captain Tupelo
launches the, the, the torpedoes against,
you know, Sean Connery on the radio,
Toba and he takes the fuses
off and then what happens?
Remember his Xo says you
killed off the thing,
comes back and syncs them. This is the
most hilarious boomerang in history,
right? I'll tell you what the
president told me in the Oval Office,
just the two of us.
It was very frustrating.
One day I think maybe Jared had
just testified or given his speech,
his little press conference,
and he said,
they will not find anything
because there is nothing,
and you know what? I take that to the
bank. There is no Russian collusion.
How could there be off for the last 15
months from arming the Ukrainians to the
XL pipeline to Anwar to finally,
after 30 years,
the first present to ever get NATO to
finally stump up the 2% of GDP that they
promised they'd spend on defense to
our own military expenditure increases.
Every significant policy decision as
president has taken with regards to Russia
has been bad for that former KGB colonel.
So the idea that with colluding,
you have to be on drugs or be so
ideologically blind to believe that,
well then what do we do with this? This
layer, you know, whatever that you,
you've referenced deep state before
[inaudible] what do we do with this thing?
You know the look,
we have an ongoing investigation to me,
the Mueller and get investigated.
What seems odd to me is that
I don't know what the actual,
I don't know that they ever laid out
with their mission is other than to find
something, what was the crime? Right?
And so the illusion to commit to
collusion to conspire in a crime.
Okay,
but what's the crime?
Because if it's Russia misrepresenting
itself or perverting the truth on
Facebook,
well then Zuckerberg should be
right charged then, then you know,
Anderson Cooper should be in the doc.
What are the charges that have been
brought outrageously ridiculous lying to
federal investigators?
You,
you would probably be able to be
caught in a perjury trap today. Okay.
Because not everybody remembers
what they did and how they did it.
Perjury traps about what you said to
somebody Irri irrespective of Russia.
That's not Donald Trump's problem.
Why a fraud eight years ago when Manafort
worked for the Ukrainian president,
what's that got to do with
Russian collusion? Nothing.
My worry is that Mueller
is not a good actor.
If you look at who is hired,
it's clear that there's massive buyers
and this report he's writing for Congress
is simply going to be a political weapon
in the elections and that's not how
justice is served.
That's not rule of law.
That's a law enforcement official
getting involved in politics,
so that's what I'm concerned about.
Also whether,
whether you think something for the
people that are watching this that thinks
something happened or didn't happen.
What I'm more concerned about is that
we're entering this new phase where
whether it's Trump that's president or
it's a Democrat that's president or it's
a different republican or whatever,
that we're just going to endlessly also
have this layer that all it does is
investigate itself, waste money. You know,
just constantly just be keeping us all
in this state where we never know what's
real. Because if you listen to
half of the pundits on television,
I mean their implication is that
Russia has installed our president,
in which case that's probably the single
biggest active board and the history of
the world.
And what are you actually saying?
Do we take Trump out and then do you take
out pants and now should Paul, right?
Have you taken to its logical conclusion
or do we have Paul Ryan as what are
your resident then and w right?
Where are you really taking this?
And that's what I'm worried about is
that we're just going to end up in this
constant state where yes,
we'll have a democrat and
then a republican or whatever,
but we'll really be caught in just con
all government can do is investigate
itself really more than anything else.
I didn't see myself as an optimist,
but you're giving me a real
challenge with that last one.
I see myself as an optimist too,
but I think, um, I'm a realist.
So for months and months,
a month,
it's all refuse to use the phrase deep
state. I really thought that was a,
you know, 10 fold, Hattie kind of thing
and one of the record,
I don't even know that I've
even said it once on this show.
It sort of pops up and answer.
I use it now because I've seen it,
I've seen it inside the administration.
When you go to enough National Security
Council meetings that are classified,
that is the, the, the,
the pinnacle of policy making in
America outside of the Oval Office.
And this is where policy's made.
Everybody's in the room from the NSC.
Then you've got the outstations
on secure VTC from Dia, uh,
chair of the joint chiefs,
CIA state, you name it, right?
And you sit there as a newly appointed
political, and you're next to,
for two hours on a big issue,
isis, Russia, whatever it is.
And not one participant mentions the
name of the president or what he said
yesterday in Warsaw or what his
objective is, given that specific issue.
And you see this happen
again and again and again.
And you're the guy at the
end of the conversation with
the funny accent and says,
excuse me, ladies and gentlemen, you do
know what the president said about X.
Yes, today. Can we actually do that?
The deep state is real when you've got
gs fifteens and ses is saying, well,
I've been here for 20 years.
I know this guy's gonna be here for four.
I know better. That's bad for
democracy. So to be clearly,
you don't think it's some sort of
massive underground conspiracy.
You think it's just the apparatus, the,
it's just the old Washington apparatus. I
don't think you have these people who
think Obama is sitting in a cave somewhere
with a joystick. He's lazy. He never be
a monster. My, he's not specter, right?
It's not Blofeld but,
but know that there's a culture in
government that's antithetical to an
undermining, undermining the
president on a daily basis.
But, but there is, there is concerted
effort in the media. Oh my gosh.
I mean Ben Rhodes brags about Ai.
That guy's unbelievable. But he says,
my buddies, the left wing journalists
are morons. And then my echo chamber,
he,
he built this machine that was,
was this incestuous connection
between people in the West Wing,
people in the think tank community
and their bodies in the media. I mean,
look at the attack pieces on anybody,
me or whatever.
It's very interesting that somebody
should do a case study agendas in school.
One attack piece will drop at 7:00
AM by two o'clock in the afternoon,
30 have been written, which are simply
cut and paste. But if you don't know that,
it looks as, oh my gosh,
go cause a fascist. No.
It's one guy's article that was written
because Ben Rhodes told them to ride it.
The Co comes and multiplies on the right.
How do we react?
Well, I got my own pet
international review this month,
right.
There's a Gulf in terms
of managing narrative.
The left built built a whole ecosystem
and we're still in the 1980s you know,
oh we'll take out a full
page ad in the Washington.
Well that's why when
discussing, right. Yeah.
I think it's so important to not or I
think most people especially just because
of the way social media works,
they immediately go to the
full on conspiracy of Obama
with a joy stick or just
some other ver,
you know the globalist thing and this
whole where to me it's like they're there.
What you just described seems more
realistic to me that there's an apparatus
there that then is still connected
to the idea that seems we can,
we can discuss that in a sensible
way with one addition and, and I,
I appreciate this not having been in
the target has in the cross hairs for so
long.
They have an advantage because our
side is predicated on what David,
the individual manifest destiny,
the rugged individualism.
We believe in individual. The left by
definition is a collective entity. I mean,
there are elements of the bog in the left,
and it is a,
it truly is a collective,
collective mob mentality.
A friend of mine on Rafe, you're watching,
I mean, thank you. There is this, when,
when, when, when one guy goes off
to gallcher or Bannon or whoever,
the president, there's this
massive collective pylon sort
of conspiracy. Yeah. But,
but it's a color.
They're all on the same hymn sheet.
They don't need direction whether say,
Oh yeah, let's go off to him, which is,
which puts us on the right
at a disadvantage. Yeah.
So this is just sort of an emergent group
thing. It's be of the cultural thing.
Yeah.
Wow. We could do, we're going to do this
again. Oh, so this is so much fun. Yeah.
This was an absolute pleasure,
uh, for more on Dr Gorka.
Can I feel like I have to say, I know,
well, I'll call you. I would if I'm a pro,
when I'm doing that later, I'll call you
Sebastian, but I feel like doctor Gorka,
I mean, you shouldn't be a star
wars character. It's all in there.
For more on Sebastian, follow him
on Twitter. It's at Seb Gorka.